hasta ahora basados en lo que conocemos
si quisiéramos ponerle el nombre a esta
molécula tendríamos que preguntarnos
cuál es la cadena de carbonos más larga
que podemos encontrar y en realidad
tenemos una cadena de dos átomos de
carbono verdad y de hecho son enlaces
simples así que realmente estamos
trabajando con un etano ok lo vamos a
escribir más adelante ahora tenemos aquí
nuestro primer carbono y es nuestro
primer carbono justamente porque aquí
tenemos los primeros grupos sustituye
entes verdad tenemos un bromo y un flúor
y por lo tanto este segundo carbono
sería lo más viajes de carbono sería el
segundo de la cadena verdad entonces
rápidamente acordándonos de las reglas
de la nomenclatura podríamos decir
fácilmente que este es el 1 bromo
1 flúor o verdad y de hecho empezamos
con bromo por la regla del orden
alfabético la beba antes que la efe y
finalmente esta molécula la cadena
principal es un etanol verdad entonces
tenemos el 1 bromo 1 flor o el flúor o
etanol
ahora bien basados inmediatamente en lo
que vimos en los vídeos anteriores este
carbono de aquí es un carbono que irá a
la verdad entonces podríamos dibujar
podríamos intentar dibujar su imagen
reflejada verdad ahí lo tienen
vamos a digamos este es el espejo así
que vamos a tratar de obtener un
enantiómero a partir de este simplemente
reflejando la verdad entonces aquí mismo
tenemos nuestro carbono que también
estará unido hacia arriba con el bromo
verdad aquí está el bromo y ahora
nuestro grupo metilo en vez de estar
hacia la derecha se encontrará hacia la
izquierda y lo importante de esto es que
se mantiene digamos tridimensionalmente
en el en el mismo plano verdad en el
plano digamos donde en la hoja donde
estamos pintando esto ahora bien el
flúor sigue permaneciendo atrás de la
hoja verdad en la misma posición digamos
y a cambio en realidad el el hidrógeno
se pasa del lado derecho y sigue estando
en su misma digamos posición por encima
de la hoja donde lo estamos pintando
ahora bien basados en la nomenclatura
que hemos desarrollado hasta ahorita
esto se llamaría también 1 bromo 1
loretano verdad se le llamaría igual que
la anterior 1 bromo 1 flor uretano pero
estas son dos moléculas fundamentalmente
distintas verdad incluso aunque tienen
los mismos átomos digamos tienen la
misma fórmula molecular en realidad
tienen la misma constitución verdad en
el sentido de que el carbono está
conectado a un hidrógeno a un flúor a un
bromo
y bueno todos todos los enlaces digamos
son esencialmente los mismos en realidad
estamos hablando de exteriores o menos
verdad son estéreo isómeros y son la
imagen reflejada mutuamente verdad a
través digamos de un de un espejo este
digamos la imagen reflejada de este y
viceversa entonces justamente por eso es
que les llamamos en anti o menos verdad
es que son en anti o menos déjenme hacer
un tantito espacio aquí verdad estos son
en anti o menos
en an
- son enantiómero y de hecho lo que se
sabe de los enantiómero ses que
polarizan la luz de forma distinta y de
hecho pueden tener digamos propiedades
químicas ya sea tienen propiedades
químicas distintas ya sea en un sistema
químico o biológico verdad y en
principio parece que no es muy bueno que
tengamos el mismo nombre para esta para
estas dos moléculas de aquí verdad así
que vamos a ir a centrarnos en este
vídeo en cómo podríamos diferenciar
estas dos moléculas o que entonces la
pregunta es cómo podríamos distinguir de
estas dos y el sistema de nomenclatura
que vamos a utilizar es el que se le
conoce como el sistema de can in gold
prelog ok entonces sería el sistema de
khan que por cierto no están comunican
academy verdad scan con c in gold
en golf reloj en el sistema de can in
gold pelo y este sistema nos ayuda a
justamente a diferenciar entre estos dos
en anti o menos verdad que de entrada se
van a llamar uno bromo uno fluoruro eta
no verdad entonces este esta forma de
asignar la nomenclatura es muy muy
sencilla o que realmente la parte
difícil es visualizar las rotaciones de
estas moléculas en la forma correcta y
digamos ver cuál es la dirección en la
que bueno digamos que podríamos
determinar si es una molécula digamos
digamos una molécula con orientación
digamos izquierda o una molécula con una
orientación derecha ok vamos a hacerlo
paso a paso y lo primero que tenemos que
hacer en el sistema de kant ingoal
prelog es identificar cuál es nuestro
átomo király esto es bastante obvio
verdad nuestro átomo quiral es
justamente este carbono
es justamente este carbono y vamos a
centrarnos por ahora en la molécula de
la izquierda después trabajamos con el
de la derecha ahora sabemos que está
unido a otros cuatro grupos diferentes
verdad y lo que tenemos que hacer es
digamos enlistar estos grupos por número
atómico así que si nos vamos a la tabla
periódica aquí está nuestra tabla
periódica vamos a tomar un color más o
menos oscuro este sirve muy bien
entonces tenemos que distinguir dónde se
encuentran estos átomos entonces tenemos
por ejemplo aquí está el bromo y vamos a
encontrar el flúor
entonces aquí tenemos el flúor tenemos
el carbono mismo verdad porque este
átomo de carbono viral está unido
directamente al átomo de carbono verdad
entonces tenemos ahí el carbono y
tenemos el hidrógeno entonces ahora
vamos a enlistar los en orden
descendente verdad es decir vamos a
tomarnos el que tiene el mayor número
atómico que este sería el bromo entonces
este sería nuestro número uno el segundo
sería el flúor el flúor porque tiene un
número atómico 9 mientras que después
sigue el carbono este sería
'creo que creo que lo puse mal este
sería el número 2 este sería el número 3
porque el carbono tiene un número
atómico 6 y finalmente el hidrógeno que
tiene un número atómico
ahora que ya los hemos enumerado lo que
tenemos que hacer es dibujar esta
molécula de tal suerte que este digamos
el átomo que tenga en la última posición
se encuentre por detrás de la página muy
bien entonces vamos a intentar hacer
esto aquí tenemos nuestro carbono y si
nos damos cuenta en este caso lo que
tenemos que hacer es rotar la molécula
en esta dirección verdad en algo así
para que nuestro hidrógeno que es el que
tiene digamos
la posición más baja quede por detrás de
la página verdad ocupa el lugar del
flúor entonces qué es lo que tendríamos
que hacer aquí tenemos nuestro carbono
que está unido al bromo
el amarillo está unido al bromo ahí lo
tienen y ahora nuestro hidrógeno se va a
encontrar en la parte trasera verdad se
encuentra en la parte trasera porque
todo esto roto en esta dirección que
pintamos ahora donde se encontraría el
grupo metilo pues ahora se encuentra en
el lado izquierdo verdad se encuentra
digamos del lado izquierdo
y tengo problemas con el color ahí está
lo tenemos del lado izquierdo pero hacia
afuera verdad ahora aquí está nuestro
grupo metilo y finalmente el flúor ocupa
la posición del metilo verdad ahí está
nuestro flúor muy bien entonces ya
pintamos la molécula de tal suerte que
el que tiene la posición más baja se
encuentra detrás de la hoja
entonces recordemos cuál era digamos la
posición este era el número 1 verdad el
número 2 era el flúor este era el número
2 el grupo metilo era digamos el número
3 y finalmente el hidrógeno es el número
4 ahora lo que nos tenemos que preguntar
es en qué sentido podemos ir del 1 al 2
y luego al 3 y si nos damos cuenta es en
este sentido que justamente es en el
sentido de las manecillas
manecillas del reloj que es en el mismo
sentido de las manecillas del reloj y
justamente por ir en el sentido de las
manecillas vamos a decir que esta es una
molécula con una orientación derecha
digamos o en realidad vamos a utilizar
en la palabra en latín para para diestro
digamos que sería rectos muy bien esto
sería rectos verdad y justamente
utilizando esto que la digamos rectos
que es la palabra para la derecha
digamos en latín vamos a decir entonces
que esta molécula esta molécula que
teníamos originalmente es la r por
rectus 1 bromo 1 bromo 1 flúor o eta no
muy bien entonces es realmente sencillo
y podemos utilizar esta misma idea para
obtener el nombre de la otra molécula
que uno pensaría bueno pues si este es
digamos la que tiene cierta orientación
éste tendrá la orientación contraria y
vamos a ver que esto es cierto entonces
como vimos para utilizar el sistema de
can in goal tenemos que recordar la
posición digamos que tenían esta según
su número atómico este era el número uno
este era el número dos verdad aquí abajo
este era el número tres y este era el
número cuatro entonces queremos
nuevamente por colocar el hidrógeno en
la posición trasera verdad entonces
tenemos que rotar digamos en este
sentido que sería rotar digamos en esta
en este en esta orientación o más bien
en esta dirección verdad así que ponemos
nuestro carbono vamos a empezar tenemos
nuestro carbono unido al bromo que se
encuentra a una arriba el hidrógeno
ahora se encuentra atrás verdad se
encontrará atrás nuestro hidrógeno y
ahora el grupo metilo se encuentra de
este lado verdad de hecho se encuentra
así justamente hacia arriba aquí está
nuestro grupo metilo y el flúor pasa a
la posición de la izquierda que
simplemente sobre la misma hoja sobre la
que se encuentra el carbono verdad
entonces recordamos las posiciones
era el número uno el flúor era el número
dos el metilo es el número tres verdad
el de atrás bueno sabemos que es el
número cuatro ahora cuál es la dirección
en la que me tengo que mover para
recorrer del 1 al 2 y luego al 3 pues es
justamente en este sentido que es el
sentido contrario a las manecillas
verdad este es el sentido contrario a
las manecillas del reloj a las
manecillas y a estos vamos a utilizar la
palabra en latín justamente para
referirnos a la izquierda que es
sinister
que ella y tenemos si míster
y en realidad la palabra sinister viene
del latín verdad para izquierdo digamos
y supongo que se referían tal vez a que
la derecha es algo bueno y la gente
pensaba que si eras nose surdo a lo
mejor harás malo pero no no sé no sé
realmente cuando tomo el significado que
tenemos hoy la palabra siniestro digamos
verdad en nuestro lenguaje común pero
esta es la versión sinister para la
molécula verdad y entonces justamente
este enantiómero podemos ponerle el
siguiente nombre vamos a ponerle ese por
zinc y esther 1 bromo
1 flúor beta no
esta no muy bien entonces ahí tenemos el
nombre para estos dos en anti o meros y
ahora podemos diferenciar los nombres
verdad sabemos que estas son dos
distintas configuraciones y utilizamos
la esa y la er para decirnos si vamos en
el sentido de las manecillas del reloj o
en el sentido contrario a las manecillas
del reloj verdad
literalmente si quisiéramos de arreglar
estas moléculas para ir de una a la otra
tendríamos que tratar digamos los
distintos grupos tendríamos que romper
enlaces tendríamos que invertir algunos
de estos grupos en algún sentido para
poder llegar de un enantiómero al otro
en antímano el experto son enantiómero
así que esencialmente son dos
configuraciones fundamentalmente
distintas verdad son estéreo isómeros
enantiómero o como sea que puedas
llamarle